[Musik]
man mag es kaum glauben wenn man ihn so
sieht aber ruins was ist ein koala mit
einem problem er kann nicht in freiheit
leben wird immer auf menschliche hilfe
angewiesen sein
die wildnis ist nichts für ihn nicht
mehr
das ist ein opfer der buschbrände
er wird im koala hospital bleiben er hat
das feuer überlebt dabei hat dabei seine
krallen verloren
alles was ihm geblieben ist sind kleine
stunden und mit denen schaffte er es
nicht sich an bäumen festzuhalten und
hochzuklettern
ich weiß noch wie wir ihn immer die
verbände gewechselt haben einer von uns
hat ihn dabei gefüttert und vier haben
sich um die wunden gekümmert
er hat das alles ertragen und seinen
appetit nicht verloren
das hat trotz allem wohl nicht schlecht
getroffen als dauergast im koala
hospital von port macquarie ist er ein
publikumsliebling und überhaupt ist er
ein glücklicher eben ein überlebender
des großen infernos vor einem jahr
allein im bundesstaat new south wales
sind 8000 koalas in den flammen
gestorben 30.000 in ganz australien das
schicksal der tiere hat weltweit für
entsetzen gesorgt
das koala hospital selbst vom feuer
bedroht wurde zur anlaufstelle 79
tierleben haben sie hier gerettet jedes
einzelne zählt denn koalas sind ohnehin
stark gefährdet heute kommen wieder
patienten mit alltäglichen koala sorgen
vom auto angefahren vom grund
angegriffen krank aufgefunden
für das team um john flanagan gibt es
also weiter viel zu tun aber sie wollen
hier nicht nur leben retten sondern
künftig auch für nachwuchs sorgen ein
zuchtprogramm für koalas das gab es noch
nie
aber spätestens nach dem feuer war klar
es ist notwendig wir wollen koalas
züchten die sich im klimawandel
behaupten können scherzhaft sage ich
immer wir wollen die meister der dürre
züchten
klingt komisch ist aber ernst das ist
wahnsinnig schwierig wenn es uns gelingt
koalas zu züchten die den klimawandel
überstehen das wäre großartig wenn
klimawandel trockenheit dürre das waren
die auslöser des flammeninfernos vor
einem jahr eine riesige fläche busch
land brannte ab
die schweiz österreich belgien die
niederlande alles zusammengerechnet
190000 quadratkilometer ein bisher
unbekanntes ausmaß
wir wissen inzwischen dass drei
milliarden tiere getötet oder vertrieben
wurden sachschäden und
gesundheitsschäden für die menschen
das alles war enorm feuer gehören in
australien zum leben dazu aber die
intensität das ausmaß sei unfassbar
und es ist eine traurige tatsache dass
wir künftig öfter mit so etwas rechnen
müssen
ein klarer beleg dafür wie weit der
klimawandel vorangeschritten ist
34 menschen starben viele andere
verloren alles haus und hof ihr gesamtes
hab und gut
mike leigh fans damals über den weg lief
durch die trümmer seines lebens da das
verbogene metallteil das war unser
schuhregal die asche das waren unsere
schuhe und dahinten das müsste der
mikrowelle sein und der wassertank aus
der küche wir waren gewarnt sind man
rechtzeitig weg haben immerhin das
wichtigste mitgenommen kinderfotos
versicherungs dokumente
das ist in sicherheit und vor allem die
familie ist in sicherheit das hier ist
doch nur ein haus was wirklich zählt und
was nicht mike hatte eine klare idee
davon und einen klaren plan wie es
weitergehen sollte neuaufbau neuanfang
hier und jetzt jetzt und hier ein jahr
später sieht die sache doch ein bisschen
anders aus die trümmer sind weggeräumt
baumaterial liegt bereit mike batt ist
ziemlich lang gewachsen und aus dem
entschlossenen australier ist im laufe
der zeit ein zweifler geworden
gefühlsmäßig waren die letzten zwölf
monate eine echte achterbahnfahrt mal
denkst du wird ihren kriegen wir hin
dann ist plötzlich jede energie weg das
zieht dich runter wie ein sumpf und dann
läuft es doch wieder es muss ja
weitergehen
aber es ist eben mal rauf mal runter und
irgendwie ist es auch noch nicht vorbei
denn mike hat noch nicht entschieden wie
es weitergeht und wo neben dem platz wo
sein haus war steht ein bahnwaggon da
war mal die idee eine ferienwohnung
daraus zu machen doch seit einem jahr
ist der waggon nun mikes zu hause
irgendwie scheint das ein sinnbild für
mike situation zu sein kommt er an oder
fährt er ab bleibt das hier seine feste
station oder ist er auf der durchreise
es ist traumhaft hier zu sehen wie die
natur zurück kommt nach und nach und das
meiste buschland ist so runter gebrannt
dass wir erst mal wohl keine größeren
feuer erleben werden
das beruhigte aber die langfristigen
aussichten da wird es wieder schlechte
nachrichten geben
und dann fragst du dich eben doch sind
wir noch am richtigen platz
nach einer langen harten zeit ist es
geradezu wundersame was die natur
tatsächlich vollbracht hat aus dem
tristen brown ist wieder ein sattes grün
geworden
das land seine menschen seine tiere
haben gelitten und narben bleiben
doch aus verkohlten stämmen sprießen
neue triebe das leben ist zurück